Hey, what's up Guys so if You've Been Following my instagram or Facebook you know I'm out in Hawaii right Now Filming a series of
Different Videos and I just got Shipped this Thing this is the Factory Prototype of the stealth Shelf for our Kickstarter that
We just launched Earlier this Month There's only A few Days Left so if You still want one go on and Grab it Really quick
I'll Show you kind of how This One Looks some of the Updates that, we're Making some of the improvements
We are Making now put some links in the Description as, [well] our Kickstarter was Successfully Funded in About Three
Days so Thank You Guys This is Happening now This Is kind of what
We're Thinking I'll come in A black Box with some Diamond plated aluminum Tread when you open it up you're Gonna have some Foam Padding
And Should find your finished Shelf this Should be Ready to Take right out of the Box and mount to your wall
Now I originally designed it to be this length Because this is the biggest Shelf you can
Make With One [Four] Foot board but now that, we're Having to Manufacture, We don't have that Constraint Anymore so?
We Can Make them a little bit longer [now] [one] [of] the biggest Questions I had on my last Video [is] how do you mount
This Thing to your Wall it's Actually very Easy [in] America
We use Sheetrock and Studs on [sixteen] inch Centers and I just Screwed This board Directly Into the Studs Giving it A lot of Durability
All I
Did Was drill a couple of Pilot holes right Here Near the Side and Took some Two and [a] half to three inch Wood Screws
And secured it straight Into the Stud now my Team Sent one of the Diy Kits to my friend zack from [Jury-Rigged] everything he put
Together A, [Step-By-Step], Tutorial Assembling The Kit and Mounting it to his Own Wall as
Well so you'll Get A good Visual on how this is going to Work
So There you have it [Guys] [The] first finished Factory Prototype of the [south] [Shelf] Elite
We're also working on A modern design as?
Well but that's what's Coming so far Go click the link in The Description Make your pledge There's only A couple of Days Left in
The Kickstarter but This is Happening Because you wanted it it looks like it's Turning Into Reality
[okay] so now on a completely Different note I'm on a wahoo right Now and I want to meet my Hawaiian
Friends so While I'm here I thought it'd be fun to do a little Meet and Greet this Tuesday from 4:30 To 5:30
Down in Honolulu Just off ala Moana
Boulevard [I've] Dropped A pin and put the link in The Description i'm also Posting on Instagram and Facebook
So Check Those social Media sites To find out Exactly Where I'm going to be Tuesday from 4:30 To 5:30
One of you in Hawaii is going to go home with this [Skell] Shelf this Is very One From this Video Follow me on
[em] and Follow me on Facebook for recent Updates and [Behind-The-Scenes] The Location Changes I will be Posting on Facebook and Instagram
So that's it Guys [Just] A quick and Dirty Update thanks so much for Following my Videos for supporting what I do!
Thanks for Joining Me for This Video See you in the next one talk to you then